[Musique]
bonsoir à tous je suis très heureux de
vous retrouver pour ce 7,8 sport le
magazine est consacrée comme vous le
savez à l'actualité sportive dans le
département a c'est parti pour le
sommaire course à pied la 41e édition du
paris versailles s'est déroulée ce
dimanche entre la tour eiffel et le
château de versailles et 25 mille
coureurs ont pris le départ cette année
les détails dans ce magazine baseball et
cougar de montigny le bretonneux ont
pris une sérieuse option sur les
demi-finales de play-off de première
division et ils montrent un mène 2 à 0
face à montpellier nous recevrons dans
quelques instants l'entraîneur de
l'équipe
rodolphe le meur sur ce plateau golf une
ryder cup étudiantes sont baptisés
jungers cup était en réalisé la semaine
dernière par l'université de versailles
saint quentin en yvelines à plaisir et
au golf de jardy reportage à suivre
l'actualité sportive de la semaine c'est
maintenant sur tv 78
[Musique]
on commence donc par de la course à pied
ont fêté ce week-end la 41e édition du
paris versailles course mythique de 16
km qui relie la tour eiffel au château
versailles et cette année à 25 mille
coureurs ont voulu se tester sur ce
parcours en montage de sandrine fontaine
ce dimanche 23 septembre devant la tour
eiffel 25 mille coureurs se sont donné
rendez vous pour participer à la 41e
édition du paris versailles
au programme de cette course mythique 16
km entre le monument parisien le château
versailles en passant par la forêt de
meudon à parcours inchangé depuis 1979
et qui séduit toujours autant les
sportifs
c'est la première que je le ferai en
plus et est franchement c'est super
parce qu'en plus des courses en ligne ça
devient de plus en plus rares ou encore
d'un point à un autre et le décor sera
dans la soif avec la nature
l'enchaînement des bottes ça permet
justement de faire un peu la différence
au niveau de ceux qui sont plus
résistants du meilleur dans les côtes
le vainqueur est lui burundais abraham
niyonkuru s'est détaché dans le sprint
final pour s'imposer en cinquante et une
minutes et trente et une secondes devant
le français gétigné g dames ou médée ça
me fait presque gagné à sa cause
les trois médias finit toujours des
viennes et j'étais content chez les
féminines c'est l'éthiopienne chaque
acquerra qui l'emportent à 22 ans la
sportive franchi la ligne d'arrivée en
1h01 et 35 secondes
elle devance la française laurie
lindekens de deux minutes tout ce beau
monde devra se retrouver l'année
prochaine pour une 42e édition du paris
versailles qu on ouvre maintenant une
page rugby dans le championnat de
division honneur les rugbymans ont
repris le championnat le championnat le
chemin de la compétition versailles
faisait sa rentrée sur le terrain de
montesson aller vers ces lions ont
remporté leur premier match dans la
douleur en s'imposant 21 à 18 une
victoire qui permet de lancer la saison
du rcv qui vise cette année une montée
en fédérale 3 avec un gros regret
recrutement effectué à l'intersaison
prochain match dimanche prochain à
domicile au stade de porchefontaine
contre le roc j fois toujours dans le
championnat de division honneur le sky
rugby a repris son championnat par un
festival offensif avec à la clé une
victoire 26 à 5 sur le terrain de melun
combs senart 77 au classement cette
victoire lors de cette première journée
permet aux saint quentinois de prendre
la place de leader
prochain match dimanche prochain à 15
heures sur le terrain de vaucresson dans
le championnat de promotion honneur
montigny le bretonneux n'a pas réussi à
lancer sa saison par une victoire sur le
terrain de noisy le sec ce dimanche trop
juste offensivement lésigny montant
s'incline 15 à 11 dans cette partie
dimanche prochain montigny le bretonneux
se rendra sur le terrain du parisis
rugby club pour tenter de décrocher sa
première victoire de la saison
un dernier résultat de rugby avant de
refermer cette page en championnat de
fédérale 2 la quatrième division
nationale plaisir n'y arrive pas l'appli
0 à se sont inclinés pour la troisième
fois en trois matches contre or ces 39 à
une défaite lourde de conséquence les
yvelinois sont avant derniers du
classement juste devant le havre
ils devront se reprendre le 6 octobre
prochain sur le terrain de beauvais
on ouvre maintenant une page baseball
les cougars de montigny le bretonneux
ont fait forte impression ce week-end en
demi-finales de play-off de première
division lésigny montant se sont imposés
lors des deux premiers matchs de leur
série lé score 4 à 3 lors de la première
partie et 10 à 0 dans la seconde
les cougars n'ont selon plus qu'à une
victoire de la finale pour nous parler
de cette performance nous recevons
sur ce plateau rodolphe le meurtre
l'entraîneur de l'équipe
bonsoir alors comment vous sentez vous
après c'est ce dimanche c'est sa vie
idyllique tout aussi déterminé c'est
vrai que là ce week-end il a été il a
été parfait en tout cas on a on appris
comme vous l'avez dit une grosse option
pour pour cette finale gagné les deux
matchs à domicile c'était vraiment
important c'était l'objectif
partir avec ces deux matches donc à
montpellier la série ken va être
déterminant psychologiquement aussi et
l'équipe est vraiment encore encore plus
déterminés arriver à cette phase de ce
championnat on est on est vraiment
confiant
vous vous attendiez à les dominer aussi
facilement surtout dans le deuxième
match un 10 à 0
non non c'est vrai qu'on on s'attendait
à voir dès le premier match on a on a eu
c'est ce combat c'est vrai que c'est
c'est montpellier on est un peu sur le
même sûr mais au niveau de jeu le
premier match a été a été compliqué mais
on a réussi quand même à aller décrocher
le 2e match c'est vrai qui je m'y
attendais pas je m'attendais pas à un
tel résultat
peut-être le un coup de massue derrière
la tête à votre avis peut-être c'est
vrai qu'ils nous ont remis un lanceur
qui qu'on avait déjà affrontées il ya
deux semaines qui nous avaient qui nous
avait mis en échec
on avait peut-être ce petit désir de
revanche face à lui donc les joueurs
sont vraiment des cons enfin ils sont
vraiment mis à fond sur ce sur ce match
et ils vont ils ont frappé il ya eu
énormément de frappe de belles frappes
et c'est surtout aussi les lanceurs qui
ont fait vraiment un travail formidable
et dans quels compartiments vous avez
été supérieur justement je dirais les
deux nouveaux lancers on a eu vraiment
de ça soit son premier match où le
deuxième match les deux lanceurs ont
fait on fait vraiment leur travail ils
ont
ils ont vraiment maîtriser leur lancée
et à la frappe c'est vrai qu'on a on a
vraiment explosé
c'est notamment sur le deuxième match
tout le travail aussi de l'entraînement
qu'on a toute la préparation qu'on a
fait tout juste avant donc cet après la
coupure du mois d'août qui est vraiment
un peu un peu dommageable c'est vrai
pour ceux pour ce championnat mais on a
vraiment beaucoup travaillé et les
efforts ont payé montpellier a terminé
deuxième du championnat juste devant
vous est ce qui vous en prie peut-être
un petit peu à la légère
non aux normes je connais très bien
l'entraîneur est pas du tout il nous a
vraiment baissé légèrement
oui parce qu'on a quand même des
statistiques qui parlent qui parle sur
le championnat on a on a le meilleur
lanceur étrangers on a parmi les 10
premiers lanceurs français cinq lanceurs
qui sont classés dans se veut se lancer
dix premiers donc on est on est attendu
ils savaient très bien que ça allait
être dur
et voilà ils nous attendaient quand même
l'année dernière vous aviez perdu en
demi finale de playoffs contre on voit
ça a été compliqué et qu'elle est
différence par rapport à l'année
dernière justement le recrutement aussi
le recrutement a été a été vraiment
exceptionnel c'est sur cette année on a
encore vu de ce qu'on a comme on appelle
des bons spots on a lanceur formidable
étrangers en franck lopez qui est là on
a recruté aussi d'autres lanceurs on a
des anciens danseurs qui ont encore
évolué qu'en qui sont encore améliorées
on a c'est vrai que le recrutement a
fait dans le sentiment d'avoir passé
peut-être un palier oui sincèrement oui
je sens en tête de l'équipe est derrière
eux c'est vrai qu'on a on a mis les
moyens aussi on a mis les moyens les
entraînements hivernaux
le recrutement tout ça et puis l'équipe
a vraiment pris pris conscience qu'on
avait quelque chose on avait vraiment un
rôle à jouer
janahi dernier en revenant dans cette
division finissant 4e
on a eu beaucoup de gens qui nous ont
sollicités qui sont venus on a fait une
grosse sélection la sélection a été
payante
et cette année vraiment on récolte les
fruits de tous ceux de tout ce
recrutement
cette demi finale perdu l'année dernière
ça va vous servir justement ce pour
conquérir cette troisième victoire oui
c'est vrai que là c'était pas la même
chose c'est vrai que l'année dernière on
a on a eu beaucoup beaucoup de mal de ce
conte et j'avais en on a joué un samedi
elle samedi j'avais six joueurs en moins
là ça va pas être le cas parce que voilà
on a tout le monde tout le monde est là
on a fait en sorte que tout le monde
puisse venir jouer c'est vrai que c'est
ce qui nous a manqué l'année dernière
c'est l'absence de quelques joueurs
cette année on a toute l'équipe toute
l'équipe et à les déterminer et elle est
prête à faire un exploit et comment vous
allez préparer vos joueurs justement
pour pas qu'ils soient dans la facilité
on va dire sur ses trois derniers
matches c'est ce que je leur ai dit à la
fin du à la fin du week-end c'est vrai
qu'on était dans l'euphorie d'avoir
gagné ces deux matches là d'avoir pris
cette grosse option et je leur ai dit
attention l'objectif n'est pas atteint
l'objectif de ces la coupe c'est
vraiment le titre en veut aller
décrocher le titre
donc il fallait qu'ils restent dans
cette détermination et que tout se joue
au mental a observé le baseball c'est ce
qu'on dit souvent c'est 80% de mental
est toujours dans la tête donc il faut
qu'on reste dans cette dynamique et avec
cette détermination qui nous a aidés à
prendre ces deux matches ce week-end
vous allez être favori sur ces matches
pour la finale vous serez forcément sur
la demi-finale sur la dila sur le match
de oui forcément quand vous arrivez avec
deux victoires vous êtes favori
maintenant personnes nous attendaient
les pronostics ne nous donnait pas
favoris voilà on va créer la surprise et
je pense qu'on va on peut faire de
belles choses encore merci beaucoup
d'être passé sur ce plateau vous le
souhaite en tout cas
mais tout est quelque chose dont j'ai
une petite juste dernière petite chose
rapidement vous m'avez parlé d'un grand
sportif qui venait à montigny
qui a fait du baseball on vous laisse la
carte mais on administre à présent sur
la ryder cup
et si vous mettez un peu de temps je
vais essayer de transmettre dans la
semaine je vais essayer de vous garantir
en tout cas merci en tout cas d'être
passée sur place tout je rappelle que la
demi finale retour est programmé ce
week-end à montpellier qu'une seule
victoire permettrait aux cougars de
montigny le bretonneux d'accéder à la
finale
on ouvre maintenant une page handball
chez les féminines montigny le
bretonneux s'est largement imposé ce
week-end pour leur premier match de la
saison à domicile dans cette nationale 2
les inimités allant dominer à patronage
laïque granville handball sur le score
de 31 à 23
un festival offensif qui permet aux
joueuses de denis chalet de remonter à
la 9e place du classement après deux
journées avec un bilan à l'équilibré
d'une victoire une défaite depuis le
début de la saison on continue à part du
handball mais cette fois ci à masculin
dans le championnat de nationale 3
plaisir s'est lourdement inclinée ce
week-end à l'extérieur sur le terrain de
saint michel ce sport score final 28 à
22 au classement les plaisirs aux as
toujours coaché par victor garrigues et
redescendre à la huitième place sur 12
équipes engagées avec une seule victoire
depuis le début de la saison prochain
match le 7 octobre prochain à domicile
contre hama si on continue à part du
football et la première division de
district ont joué ce week-end la
deuxième journée du championnat plaisir
s'est imposé ce dimanche contre toulouse
sur le score de 2 buts à 1 un résultat
qui permet aux plaisirs wa d'occuper la
deuxième place du classement de son côté
le chili n'a fait qu'une bouchée de
gargenville ce qu'en finale à 5 buts à 1
but en cours est monté son se sont
neutralisées 2 buts partout
sartrouville s'impose contre le fc
mantois 3 marly-le-roi domine
hardricourt 2-0 enfin maurepas s'incline
à à 0 contre carrière et grésillons on
ouvre une page golf la fièvre de la
ryder cup a également touché
l'université de versailles saint quentin
en yvelines
la structure organisée ce mercredi et
jeudi la jungers cup une compétition
étudiante opposant des golfeurs français
et étrangers sur le thème de la ryder
cup à remontage de julo grenouille il
des polos rouges et bleus sur un
parcours de golf ce mercredi 19
septembre l'esprit de la ryder cup s'est
emparé du golfe isabella de plaisir à
l'occasion de la première édition de la
young hearts cup
le concept la compétition oppose des
étudiants français et étrangers
rendez vous imaginé et organisé par nous
assistée de versailles saint quentin en
yvelines pour monter une opération était
la mère murger commun s'il fallait que
j'ai à la fois des relais au niveau des
étudiants français dont j'ai sollicité
les professeurs des universités
franciliennes et du côté étranger dans
un premier temps j'essayais d'avoir des
relais auprès des écoles britanniques
américaines de la région parisienne
au total quatorze joueurs lui français
six étrangers ont répondu présents pour
ce rendez vous elle se trouve que l'idée
super cool de faire une compétition
juste avant la ryder cup pour avoir le
feeling oui j'aime j'aime bien ça permet
de vivre un peu mieux la ryder cup en
veut plus ensemble voilà c'est génial
parmi les étudiants on retrouvait
notamment la fille de la légende du golf
français jean van de velde joueurs sur
la ryder cup en 1999 est un franco
suisse alexandre a enfilé le temps d'une
journée le polo des états unis et non
pas de l'europe comme son père ça me
fait un peu bizarre je pense que mon
père va être content mais après les
matches la journée s'est terminée au
club house par un quiz sur la ryder cup
les deux équipes ont dû se creuser les
méninges pour répondre à une dizaine de
questions de culture générale sur la
compétition dans la mesure où cet
événement est porté par l'université il
fallait qu'à une petite connotation donc
culturelle
voilà donc on a essayé de mêler culture
et sport la compétition s'est clôturé ce
jeudi 20 septembre golf de jardy à
vaucresson une onzième édition pourrait
être organisé dans deux ans lors d'une
prochaine ryder cup c'est la fin de
cette émission merci de l'avoir suivi on
se retrouve lundi prochain pour un
nouveau magazine vous retrouver dans
quelques instants une émission spéciale
sur la ryder cup à
saint-quentin-en-yvelines tous les
détails sur cette compétition avec
wilfrid richy très belle soirée sur tv à
[Musique]